this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Bill for that very kind
introduction
it's the microphone on and can you can
you hear me okay okay great so it's a
real pleasure to be here today to tell
you about the last five years of work in
my lab now there's no way I can tell you
about all the last five years of work in
my lab we'd be here all afternoon so I'm
going to focus on a couple of stories
and one of the real themes emerging from
the research in my lab is the importance
of variability in plant development and
I'm going to tell you two stories about
variability today and variability is
something we don't often think about as
biologists it's something we kind of
sweep under the rug we do our
experiments we get a number of
replicates we take the average we put
the error bars on we hope the error bars
are small and that's about it but I the
theme emerging from my labs research is
that the variability is actually really
important and we need to pay attention
to it so one of the fundamental
maybe we should yeah is that okay with
everyone there is it should we try this
one you know this one there we go okay
one of the fundamental question
characteristics of all organisms is
their size from the giant sequoia tree
to the small flowering plant wolf eeeh
or the mouse to the elephant and the
organ size needs to follow the organism
so a mouse has a very small liver
whereas an elephant has a very large
liver a couple years ago in science
magazine the question of how two organs
know when they've reached the right size
and decide to stop growing is one of the
fundamental mysteries in developmental
biology and fundamentally organ size is
really simple it's controlled by the
number and size of the cells in the
organ and so in theory if you just
increase the cell number you'll get a
bigger organ or if you crease the cell
size you'll get a bigger organ now as
probably most of you know reality is
nowhere near this simple and we'll come
back to that
closely related species often have
different sizes here's a rabid OPS's
belly on a flower and here's a rabbit
OPS's la rata flower you can see that
they have the same organs in the flower
on a petal is much smaller than the arab
adopts esperado petal and it's been said
that size is the material that evolution
largely works on but the fields really
in the dark about how this happens we
don't know the mechanisms of how size
changes but since it's worked on by
evolution it means that there has to be
some genetic control which gives us a
handle to get in here
within a single species size is very
consistent so these are our rabbit ops
italiana petals and you can see they're
all the same size and shape and so when
we're thinking about plants but think
about organs like floral organs as
petals sepals stamens carpals so one of
the fundamental questions is how two
organs form with a reproducible size and
shape and this is a very broad question
it applies to us humans and it applies
to plants
so as humans you can think about your
two arms your two your arms are the same
length with a precision of point zero
two and if you think about when you're
developing when your smile small child
your arms are also the same length and
then as you become an adult they grow
and throughout that period they would
maintain the same length the same thing
is true in plants in sepals so the sepal
is the outermost green leaf light floral
organ and the first thing the sepal does
is grow and protect the floral meristem
and then developing reproductives and
organs inside the flower and there are
four sepals on each or Abid OPS's flower
and those four sequels have to be the
same size to enclose the flower and
protect the bud
and it's the same with humans they start
out very small and they have to maintain
the same size throughout their growth as
the flower is developing from the young
sepals here in the middle to be older
sepals out here to maintain this closure
and protection here's 4 sepals from a
flower you can see they're really very
similar size and shape what makes the
reproducibility of Oregon's size
particularly mysterious is the finding
in many organisms that cells are highly
variable and if we take sepals as an
example sepals have highly variable cell
size they've got this beautiful pattern
of giant cells which are false colored
here in red interspersed between a whole
range of smaller cell sizes so there's a
ton of variability in cell size there's
also a ton of variability growth rates
so here I'm showing you a heat map of a
young developing seat bowl and I'm gonna
show you a bunch of heat maps throughout
the talk in this case red is growing
fast and blue is growing slow so you can
see there's a ton of variability in
these cells and their growth rates
you've got cells that are growing fast
right next to cells that are growing
very slowly and if we think about plant
cells their growth is regulated by the
cell wall mechanics and the turgor
pressure inside so we also have looked
at cell wall mechanics and find that
they're highly variable as well so in
collaboration with a rescue balloon and
the till Du Monde we did atomic force
microscopy to look at the cell wall
mechanics called properties so here's
another heat map in this case red is
stiff and blue is soft and we've traced
the outlines of the cells here in black
over the afm data you can see that we've
got soft stiff patches right next to
soft patches so there's a ton of
variability in the cell wall properties
as well so at the cellular level and
even sub cellular level we see a ton of
variability how do we go from this
cellular variability to get regular
organs and the rabbit off the steeple is
a particularly good model system for
looking at this question particularly
because it's relatively invariant to
environmental fluctuations now in the
future of course we want to understand
how the environment actually regulates
growth but to start we need to
understand growth to begin with without
the input of the environment so floral
organs are relatively invariant to the
environment the flower is also
particularly good because it has four
sepals and that allows us to compare
organize within a single flower in
addition there's sixty to a hundred seat
flowers per plant so we can really get a
statistical analysis of sepal size
within a single plant and finally it's
accessible for live imaging and
manipulation and one of the experiments
that we love to do in my lab is live
imaging so we take our living plant
attach it to a slide stuff it under the
confocal microscope and take an image
and then we put it back in the growth
chamber let it grow for another 6 8 12
hours depending on the experiment and
then it put it back on the microscope
and image the same sepal again and
here's just an example of a few cells
we've got the nuclei marked in gold and
the plasma memories are really faint and
they're also in gold you can see there's
three cells here than six hours later
this cell has divided to make two cells
here this cell has divided to make these
two cells
and this cell has just grown so we can
track what's going on in each of the
cells over time so here's an example of
that live imaging you can see the sepals
growing tremendously the nuclei are
moving around some cells are dividing
and in collaboration with Gerardo Terry
yellow then picked up tsukumo Zachos we
developed a method for tracking the cell
lineages so tracking each cell in all of
its descendants we've colored each cell
in its descendants by the same color and
you can see here that this giant cell
that formed never went and under what
any divisions is all one cell and this
purple patch here went through a lot of
divisions so there's many cells we
incorporated this into the Morpho
graphic software package that richard
smith developed and this has been
published in Elife as part of the more
for graphic software package
so the main question is how to sell
their variability give rise to organ
regularity and there's two sides of this
question that I'm gonna look at today
the first is what mechanisms generate
the cellular variability and this is the
work of my graduate student
Heather Meyer who just defended her PhD
and the second question is how do
variable cells produce uniform organs
and this is the work of my postdoc dr.
Leland home okay so let's start with
this first question how do we get this
cell variability and we want to look at
this as a typical patterning question
and ask particularly about giant cells
how do we get the pattern of giant cells
interspersed between small cells and so
if we think about this in a
developmental patterning setting would
think about we've got a small immature
sepal primordium where the cells are all
uniform they're all the same and how
does a single cell decide it's going to
divide to become a giant cell or it's
going to become a small cell so everyone
always asked me what's the purpose of
giant cells they have an effect on
Oregon curvature so in a wild-type
sequel we've got interspersed giant
cells and the sepals straighten up when
the flower blooms and protect the base
if we have plants with too many giant
cells then the sepals splay outward and
they open up too early so that
developing flower bud is not protected
and it's not protecting the base here
either if we have sepals with no giant
cells they have a very subtle inward
curvature defect they're curved too much
inward they're not straightening up as
the flower blooms to sit nicely along
the base of the flower
and if we have a double mutant that
loses giant cells then spasibo start to
roll up on themselves
you see it's completely rolling up and
because of this it's not protecting the
flower very well either so giant cells
have a role in sepal curvature we've
previously shown that giant cells formed
through a specialized cell cycle called
end or duplication during the normal
cell cycle cells grow in g1 replicate
their DNA and S phase grow in g2 and
then divided an M phase and keep on
going through the cell cycle during
endure duplication cells exit the
mitotic cell cycle and grow replicate
their DNA and grow and keep on growing
and replicating their DNA becoming
enlarged and polyploid so that's how you
get these big giant cells if we measure
DNA content using flow cytometry to
measure how many endo cycles is
undergone we can see we have to see
diploid cells that's the starting point
they replicate their DNA once a 4c twice
to 83 times the 16 seat or four times to
32 seat this is these 16 C and 32 C
cells that are the giant cells and if we
look at the relationship between DNA
content and cells area or we find that
it's linearly correlated so the giant
cells are the 16 C cells
and from our previous live imaging data
we've seen how these giant cells form so
if we take two and I'm going to show you
a very simplified model here if we take
to see diploid cells in our cito
primordium they replicate their DNA to
4c during the cell cycle if these two
divide they go back to being two seed
diploid cells whereas if this one Endora
duplicates it becomes a 4c cell now once
a cell under a duplicate it generally
cannot go back and divide again so it's
going to enter a duplicate again
so this 4c cell under duple gets to be
an 8c cell this cell maybe decides to
enter a duplicate and become a 4c cell
and the rest of cells might decide to
divide in the next cell cycle this 8c
cell is going to become a 16 C giant
cell this 4c cell is going to become an
8c cell maybe the cell under duplicates
to become a 4c selling the rest of mine
so what you can see here is that the
pattern of cell sizes develops just
based on the time at which each cell
decides to end or duplicate if it end
decides to end or duplicate very early
it becomes very enlarged and becomes a
giant cell if it end or duplicate slate
it does not okay so we've got one answer
to our question how do we get this
variability it's by variability in the
timing of end or duplication but it
still leaves us with another question
how does an individual cell decide
whether it's going to divide and become
small or under a duplicate and become
large so to start to get out this
question when I was a postdoc I started
a mutant screen and we finished this
mutant screen in my lab looking for
mutants that effect giant cell formation
and we pulled out quite a number of
mutants one is a cell cycle regulator
that will come back to there's a number
of mutants in the
Thermal specification pathway this was
quite a surprise and there was one
mutant with ectopic giant cells it's
involved in sub cellular trafficking and
this was the work of my first graduate
student Sheehan and he published it a
nice plant physiology paper on that but
today I want to focus on the AML one
gene in 1801 unit you can see the HTML 1
mutant completely lacks giant cells ATM
l1 encodes a homeodomain leucine zipper
transcription factor and it's involved
in epidermal specification so here's the
protein structure you've got a homeo
domain a leucine zipper domain and a
start domain atmo one is expressed
throughout the epidermis including in
young sepals so here's here's a young
seat bow you can see it's expressed in
all that outer layer of cells 80 ml one
is well known for its role in epidermal
specification based on the work of avi
at all who found that atmo mutations in
1801 and its sister gene PDF to cause a
loss of epidermal identity so in
wild-type or got a scanning electron
micrograph and we're looking down on the
surface you can see here's the epidermis
and it's been peeled back to reveal the
musa phil cells underneath and the HTML
one PDF - double mutant and poor plant
has its music phil expose there's no
epidermis overlying it if it's amazing
is that those plants will actually
germinate on soil but then they
desiccating croak it's pretty bad not to
have an epidermis
conversely if you overexpress atmo one
throughout all the cell layers then you
start to get epidermal cell types
forming in the internal layers here's a
wild-type cotyledon and you can see
here's the epidermis and in the
epidermis there these stomata which are
staying dark blue which allow for gas
exchange when a Samoans over expressed
in all cell layers you start to get
stomata developing in the internal musa
phil cells that's really toxic to the
plant and these guys die too so dead or
dead but the question we have is since
1800 one is expressed in every cell in
the sepal epidermis how is it that only
specifies some of them to become giant
cells and so we know from the HTML one
signal meaning that still has an
epidermis and yet it's completely
lacking these giant cells this is a
question that fascinated Heather and so
what we have to ask is what happens if
we overexpress atmo one just in the
epidermis so we're not over expressing
it in the inner cell layers we're not
talking lethality here now we get this
spectacular phenotype anthias is in
collaboration with Rita San bento and
Gwyneth Ingram these peoples are
completely covered in giant cells so
just over expressing atmo one in the
epidermis just increasing the levels is
sufficient to make sepals with all giant
cells and that tells us that levels of
80ml 1 are really important in this
patterning process
so Heather explored this further and
asked the question how do different
genetic levels of atmo one influence the
number of giant cells so just showing
you that HMO and overexpression make
steeples with all giant cells if we
reduce the level of atmo 1 by making the
transgene heterozygous we find still a
lot of giant cells but now a few cells
escape and become small cells so
reducing atmo 1 reduces the number of
jetan cells we can take this a step
further by removing the endogenous atmo
1 by crossing this into the mutant and
we can see that in that case we still
have ectopic giant cells but even fewer
of them and finally the final test is if
we look at a heterozygous mutant that
should have less 80ml 1 than wild-type
we should get fewer giant cells and
that's exactly what we see so there's a
beautiful dosage dependency of the
number of giant cells on the genetic
level of atmo 1 ok so we wanted to
verify this not just with imaging but
with another mechanism so Heather did
flow cytometry to look at the end or
duplication remember giant cells are
highly and/or duplicated so we're only
looking at the highly end or duplicated
cells and we see a very nice radiation
in the number of 16c giant cells on
these lines so the overexpression
homozygous has a lot and it goes down to
the mutant which has very very few
what's even more remarkable is that the
overexpression line actually increases
end or duplication we start to see 64c
cells with an extra in disciple that we
don't see in
type so clearly the dosage of 80 ml one
is really important for controlling the
number of giant cells in the sepal but
this raises a question the wild type
where we've got some cells becoming
giant and some cells not becoming giant
they all have the same dosage of 80 ml
one this is wild type plants they've got
two copies of bacon with one gene so
there's a couple of possibilities here
either the cells exhibit varying
responses to the same 80 ml one
concentration or 80 ml one
concentrations vary between cells now to
test these two possibilities Heather
generated an 80 ml 1 fluorescent fusion
protein reporter so she's got the whole
upstream promoter region she's got the
MCG fluorescent protein fused to 80 ml 1
and the downstream 3 prime UTR region
and she transformed this into 80 ml one
mutant plant and selected lines where it
rescues the wild-type number of giant
cells this is really important because
this tells us that this trans gene is
functional so the atmo one here is the
only atmo one it's making the giant
sauce and it also tells us that this
atmo one is expressed at the right level
so what we see is going to accurately
reflect producing the wild-type number
of giant cells
okay so what what do we see in this line
well we see that different cells have
different concentrations of atmo one so
here's here's the atmo one fluorescent
for fusion protein reporter and it's
little nuclear localized because there's
a transcription factor so what you're
seeing here all these dots are different
nuclei and you can see that some have
very high concentrations of atmo and
very bright and its neighbor is a little
bit lower over here there's a really
bright one here's one that's so dim you
can barely see it
so there's definitely different
concentrations of atmo one in these
different epidermal cells and this is a
point at which giant cells this is
before giant cells have been established
this is before before the specification
has taken place so how does one cell get
a higher level of HTML one expression
than its neighbor and this made us think
about the fact that gene expression is
stochastic there's been a lot of studies
showing that gene expression fluctuates
up and down so we hypothesize that maybe
8:01 concentrations fluctuate in each
cell randomly and maybe this is the
patterning mechanism
so if atmo one is fluctuating up and
down if it passes a threshold meaning
that cell goes on to become a giant cell
whereas another cell that never crosses
that threshold goes on to become a small
cell this fits with our genetic data so
if we increase the expression of a team
on one we're going to bump all this
fluctuation up above the threshold and
now everything's going to become a giant
cell
in the HTML one mutant now everything's
below the threshold and nothing's going
to become a giant cell cuz there's no
80ml one okay so now we need to test
this by live imaging so how their live
image these HTML one reporters every
eight hours and here's the here's the
movie showing you the development over
eight hours over well every eight hours
over many hours and we collaborated with
Henrik Johnson James Locke and their
postdocs josée tell us and POW for most
of Jordan at the Sainsbury laboratory at
University of Cambridge to quantify atmo
one in each cell over time and to create
a model so Heather actually flew over to
Cambridge and worked with josée on
developing a quantification pipeline and
this is a real tour de force so they
take the raw image they segment every
single nucleus which means detect each
one individually they take different
time points and align them using alt and
then can track the cell lineages over
time so we've got the sixteen hour time
point in red in the 24 hour time point
and green and if it's the nucleus is
yellow that means that it's the same
nucleus and if it's divided then they
track which one's descended from which
and measure the 80 ml one concentration
in the nucleus and then put all this
data together so that we can track
individual nuclei how their HMO one
concentration fluctuates and this is
just a hit it does fluctuate okay so we
have two predictions to be tested from
the model the first is that before cell
becomes giant HMO one level should be
above the threshold and the second is
that if a cell is going to remain small
that atmo one level should not surpass
the threshold and the key here is that
this should all happen before the fate
is decided so that it's predictive okay
so here's what we see we've got all the
cells in the sepal epidermis giant cells
are in red small cells are blue you can
see first of all but it does fluctuate
that's very dramatic
the second the hypothesis is less clear
though you can see that in general the
giant cells tend to reach high levels of
a tumor one so here's HMO low
concentration high levels over time but
some of the blue cells actually reach
very very high concentration so some
small cells are getting way up here in
the concentration so then how they're
thought about this a little bit more and
asked is there any cell cycle dependence
because n reduplication decision is
probably made during g2 and so she
determined the cell cycle by looking at
the nuclear area so in this is a cell
that goes through g2 its large it
divides g1 nuclei are smaller here's the
graph showing a nuclear area over time
it's large in G two divides two smaller
nuclei so you can use the nuclear area
to determine the stage of the cell cycle
and throughout I'm going to show you
jeetu in light blue and g1 in yellow so
let's take a look at a couple cells here
we've got a cell that starts out in g1
it goes through g2 it's got a very high
concentration of HTML 1 and G 2 and then
it goes on Android duplicates and
becomes a giant cell so we plot this on
the graph and we drive a threshold for
HTML 1 you can see that this cell
crosses the threshold and then becomes a
giant cell
now here's another cell but has lower
concentrations of HTML wondering g2 it
never quite makes it past the threshold
and it divides and goes on to become too
small cells
here's another cell that is above the
threshold in g1 but it's also above the
threshold in g2 and it goes on to enter
a duplicate where's this cell crosses
the threshold in g1 but that doesn't
have any effect in g2 it's below the
threshold and it goes on and divides so
we're seeing a clear cell cycle
dependence if the cells in g2 and the
HTML one crosses the threshold then it
becomes a giant cell so we wanted to
quantify this using receiver operator
characteristic and find the threshold
this way so if we look at all the cell's
in g1 and we take the peak a t-mobile
and concentration before it makes a
decision so the top one we can plot it
here and you see we've got fairly
overlapping distributions here and if we
do look at the true positives versus the
false positives it basically follows the
random line and we get a 54%
productivity which basically means we
have no productivity here so not
predictive in g1
whereas if we look at g2 phase so we've
got again the peak 18:01
you can see that now this distributes
better the giant cells tend to have a
higher peak 18001 than the small cells
if we plot true positives versus false
positives then we get 82% productivity
and so this one is predictive so g2
phase HMO concentration in g2 phase is
predictive okay so in summary we've got
the HMO one concentration in g1 phase
doesn't tell us anything but in g2 phase
if HMO one is low it's going to go
through mitosis and divide whereas if
it's high it's going to go on and end or
duplicate and become a giant cell so we
put this into a model this is developed
by Pao Formosa Jordan so 80 ml one in
every single cell we've got 80 ml one
it's got a concentration that changes in
time based on production there's a
production term degradation degradation
term and a positive feedback loop that
we hypothesize because HTML one has its
own binding site in its promoter and it
turns out in the model we it can work
whether we have or do not have this
positive feedback loop so it's actually
not necessary and then we put stochastic
noise into every single part of this
equation so everything is a little bit
random and so then we think that atmo
one must control some downstream target
gene given that it's a transcription
factor so we act activating something
and that downstream target gene is going
to regulate the cell cycle only in g2
phase to promote end or duplication and
inhibit mitosis so we've got this cell
cycle timer here and it's just
oscillating up and down to give us a
cell cycle time but the behavior of HTML
one versus a target is really
interesting because it produces a soft
threshold so the target has to cross a
threshold during g2 to make a cell under
duplicate and become giant it generally
follows atmo one but there's a lot of
stochasticity here so sometimes HTML one
will cross so we've got HTML one
concentration target if HTML one crosses
its threshold but the target does not
then the cell is going to divide whereas
if the target crushes the threshold but
HTML 1 does not then the cell is going
to end or duplicate so that might
explain this 82 percent productivity
we've got we've got soft threshold here
okay so how does the model look well it
looks very much like the data so we've
got 800 one concentrations fluctuating
up and down if they surpass a threshold
in g2 then this all goes on under
reduplication
the cell does not pass the threshold in
g2 it's going to keep dividing and
dividing and even if
passes the threshold of g1 it keeps
dividing here's the model we've got a
team on fluctuating up and down we've
got the target fluctuating up and down
following a team l1 we've got the timer
that's just doing the soft cycle and
here we've got these cell size pattern
developing so we've got the ploidy so
again the 2c is in yellow 4c is in blue
and if it Endor duplicates it becomes
red and then purple than green so let's
play that movie again and you can watch
the ploidy and see that the cells are
going to 4c then they're dividing going
back to 2c but then sometimes they
decide to end or duplicate and become
red and then those cells and to renew
placate further and become giant cells
so we the model is developing a pattern
of giant cells interspersed between
smaller cells so can the model reproduce
our beautiful dosage series yes it can
if we just varied the HTML one
production rate we can get the whole
range of different numbers of giant
cells from all giant cells down to you
know a few giant cells like wild-type
down to no giant cells in the mutant
so in conclusion we've really discovered
a new patterning mechanism based on
fluctuations of a transcription factor
atmo one fluctuates up and down in the
sepal primordium cells and in the hi
stage during g2 it promotes end
replication and causes the formation of
a giant cell whereas if it's low
throughout g2 then the cell divides and
becomes a small cell and this is really
fascinating because modeling has long
predicted that there should be slight
fluctuations of the activators of cell
fate to promote patterning even if it's
a regular pattern they need to be
initiated by very small differences
between cells so here's a model based on
the formation of trichomes or hair cells
and you've got the activators very
slightly fluctuating randomly and that
sets up the regular pattern of trichome
spacing so we are now seeing very much
amplified fluctuations that are doing
the patterning so this is the work of
Heather as I said and she just defended
her PhD and the papers in revision for
Elife and of course this is not the end
of the story we have a lot of future
questions which are what gene says atmo
one regulate to produce giant cells and
how do these genes respond to different
concentrations of 18:01 to enact a
threshold and what about the other
epidermal specification genes we found
involved in giant cell development are
the upstream downstream or enough
possibly in a feedback loop and Lila
Luna just joined the lab and she's
working on these questions and this is
work funded by a five year NSF career
grant
and then we're also looking at Lego and
I mentioned Lego in the very beginning
as one of the other mutants it doesn't
have any giant cells Lego encodes a cell
cycle regulator that's involved in
hitting cyclin-cdk complexes and it
promotes end or duplication so the
question is does Lego follow the
predictions in the model for the target
and Dana is working on this one
prediction is that Lego should be dosage
dependent like atmo one and that's
exactly what dana sees so you can get
big radiation from all giant cells so no
giant cells by modulating the genetic
dosage of Lego okay so we need to come
back to the question of Oregon's size
here and ask how to cell size affect
organ size this was our original
hypothesis but as you can see the number
of giant cells has absolutely no effect
on organ size whatsoever so you can go
from very few very large cells to many
small cells and the sepal so here's
sepal area and here's the different
genotypes they're all basically exactly
the same this is the work of Dana
so this brings up the mystery of
compensation which is well known in
plant biology when there some
perturbation happens in there's fewer
cells they increase their size to get
nearly normal organ size whereas if
there's more cells they decrease their
size to get nearly normal organ size so
obviously organ size is much more
complicated what we've seen is that the
way this happens is in part because
growth does not depend on cell division
so Gerardo and Heather published a very
nice paper in plant physiology where
they analyzed the growth of sepal cells
and so here's a single cell lineage so
we've got this and it grows like this
over time and in each cell division
event is marked with an orange arrow you
can see that cell division has
absolutely no effect on the growth if we
look at all the cells in the sepal and
look at okay the red is all the cell's
purple is the non-dividing and Daru
duplicating cells and green is the
dividing cells and their growth curves
are essentially exactly identical so it
doesn't matter for cells dividing or in
duplicating is growing the same way and
that's how you get this trade-off where
and reduplication versus division does
not affect sepals area okay so we have
completely not answered the question of
sepal size so now we need to look at how
do variable cells promote these uniform
organs and this is a again this is the
project work on my my postdoc dr. Whelan
home and it's a question that fascinated
an international interdisciplinary team
of research and we got a human frontiers
grant to fund this work so we're the
biologists and we work together with a
rescue Buddhahood
you want Olivia's a cell biologist and a
rescues of physicists and France we work
with Richard Smith who I mentioned
before who created the more for graphic
software in Cologne Germany and Jim
bewdley and tamika come up Sasaki in
Japan here we are all in Germany
drinking five liters of beer and we made
it through more than one of those and as
I said this is funded by human frontiers
program so the question that fascinated
us is the same question we've been
talking about how do you go from
cellular variability to organ regularity
well as geneticists if we want to know
what controls a process we need to
disrupt it so we need to find a mutant
that disrupts the process and if we want
to know what creates regular organs we
need to find mutants that don't have
regular organs that have variable organs
so we screen for mutants with variable
sepal size in the same flower and this
is a really novel screen no one has done
this before screening for variable organ
sizing either plants or animals people
have screened for bigger or smaller but
never variable and it's one of the first
screens to actually look for variability
at all there's been a few previous
screens in yeast and Leland found the
spectacular mutant called FTS h4 and FQ
stage four completely nails variability
it's got everything going on so here's
here's our wild-type flower and it's got
its four same size sepals here's three
different F G SH four flowers from the
same plant one is perfectly normal one
this one has one normal sepal here and a
couple smaller sepals here you can see
it also affects the other floral organs
and this poor flower has all four
smaller sepals if we look at earlier
stages where the sepals in wild-type
close the flower bud because they're all
the same size we can see again there's
some normal flowers and there are some
flowers that are open
has it got smaller sepals some normal
sepals and some smaller sepals so Leland
quantified this to verify we've got
sepal area and wild-type has a very
small variability in sepal area whereas
f2 stage for mutants have a much larger
variability in sepal area and so the
next question is when does the defect
arise is this a problem in growth versus
a problem in initiation so Leland looked
at very early simple development the
sepals arise as primordia on the flanks
of the floral meristem here you've got
the four sepals they rapidly grow and
start to cover the floor immerse them
and they completely cover it and close
the seat the flower here in F th for the
C pole primordia rise normally they
start to grow normally and it's when
they're trying to close the flower that
you see it start to see problems if
flowers not quite closing the sepals
lagging behind it's not catching up the
sepals lagging behind and leaving a gap
and again another gap is forming so the
problem is not in the initiation but in
the growth of the sepals so we wanted to
think about this from a modeling
perspective and ask the question you
know how to sell you a variability give
rise to organ regularity and we need to
think about what we should look at here
and so we started with some modeling and
we base the modeling on our atomic force
microscopy data looking at variability
in cell wall stiffness so rescue Matilda
made a model where they've got a
mechanical sheet of tissue and they put
different stiffnesses into it so black
is stiff and great a white is soft and
they replicate this variability based on
the atomic force microscopy data and
then they see what happens
oh we got a nose that's definitely not a
sepal and if we run this model again
again from different starting conditions
we never get a people out we might get a
Drosophila wing or like a wing disc or
something but we never get a sepal so
clearly this model that has variability
in space does not produce regular sepals
but then we thought what if we make
variability in space and in time so the
idea here is that each element is
changing its stiffness in time you can
see that sometimes it's soft sometimes
it's stiff and that's producing very
regular sepals if we run it again and
again we get lots of regular sepals so
variability in space and in time leads
to regular sepals now these are pretty
extreme models this doesn't represent
wild-type ramune these are extremes but
they give us an idea what to think about
and what to look for in the biology and
so in its virtual sepal we see that
cellular variability in space plus
seller variability in time gives us
regular organ morphology and the
question is is that what happens in the
real sepal this is what's going on so we
went did live imaging where she's
watching the seagull grow and she's got
a plasma Marine marker so she can track
every cell in its growth here's
wild-type here's the mutant neftis h4
mutant you can see that it's having its
typical problem where the sepals aren't
closing because the growth isn't quite
right
and so if she uses more for graphics to
analyze the growth in every cell and
we've got a heat map here with red
growth red fast growth and blue slow
you can see in wild-type there's
considerable variability and growth and
then the mutant it looks also fairly
variable so we took a very close look at
the variability and first we know we
need to analyze the variability in space
and so we take each cell and look at all
of its neighbors and assess how variable
is this cell relative to it how variable
our neighboring cells and we do that
throughout the sepal we get an average
variability and so we've got wild-type
plotted in blue here mutant plotted in
pink and so going from low variability
to high variability over time and what
we find is actually wild-type is more
variable from the mutant now initially
without the modeling this would be a
huge surprise how is more variability
giving rise to more regular organs and
less variability gives more screwed up
organs you can see here's the average
wild-type it's definitely above the
average mutant so then we know we need
to look at variability in time as well
that's the next part of the model so we
look at a cell and how much does its
growth rate change at the next time
point so this one changes a lot and this
one changes very little and then we see
that wild type of mutant are largely
overlapping so there's high variability
to low variability on the y-axis and
time
the x-axis and you can see that the blue
wild-type and the pink mutant are maybe
the mutants a little less variable but
they're overlapping enough it I will
call it even
finally we looked at variability in cell
wall mechanics cell while stiffness
using atomic force microscopy and so
we're looking at how does each spot
relate to its neighboring spots and wild
type versus mutant so we've got
variability here and wild type is more
spatially variable than the music so
again the Lita's has reduced variability
so in wild-type we've got high
variability and space high variability
in time and this is regular seat bolts
whereas in the mutant we've got low
variability in space about the same
variability in time and this is
producing irregular seat bones so we
wanted to test this in the model if we
reduced variability in space do we get
more irregular seat bones like what we
see in the mutant so here's our normal
seat bones with high very building space
and time if we reduce the variability in
space and that means making each of
these spots bigger so that's what you're
seeing here bigger spots so reduced
variability then we get more irregular
sepals you can see these are not as
regular got different slightly different
sizes and different shapes so that is
much more like the mutant so just
reducing variability in space can
produce more like mutant phenotype
and so then we asked how do you go from
cellular variability to Oregon regular
organ morphology with the southern
variability of space and time and leland
looked at the principal direction of
growth which is the main direction cells
growing in so if you take this green
cell and it grows to be this red cell
it's growing mostly in this direction so
we've got a little line here indicating
that that's shown by the white lines
here on each cell and so over each
24-hour period you can see there's quite
a bit of variability in growth direction
that's what we expect we see a ton of
variability but what's remarkable is if
we look over the whole 48 hour interval
at the growth we see that now suddenly
it's aligning most of these growth
directions of these cells over 48 hours
have a line and so that the sepal is
growing much more normally over a long
time you can see how this happens this
cells pointing a little bit to the right
then it's pointing a little bit to the
left and that averages out to point with
this overall growth of the seat Bowl so
cellular variability is undergoing
spatial temporal averaging this is a
concept from physics that we're now
seeing in biology to produce organ
regularity
so what about the mutant the mutants
variable and variable but it doesn't do
this spatial-temporal averaging after 48
hours the directions are still highly
variable and it if you go longer it
still does an average so this cell is
growing quite to the right it's still
growing a bit to the right and it over
48 hours it's growing a bit to the right
so it's not average incurring so what
causes the failure or spatial temporal
averaging in fds h4 immunes we like used
positional cloning clone the gene and
found much to our surprise it's a
mitochondrial protease
so this prettiest has a ATPase domain
and a Proteus domain and it sits in the
inner membrane of the mitochondria and
it's a bit of a garbage collector it's
degrading unfolded proteins particularly
in the ox vas pathway it can also help
proteins fold so it's it's doing both
sides of quality control and it really
mutates to this variable organ size
phenotype Leyland pulled out six
different alleles in our screen in this
gene FGS h4 is highly conserved across
kingdoms
so it's here's the conservation from a
rabbit OPS's to human to yeast to e.coli
and you can see in the Proteus domain
underlined in red and the sorry the
ATPase domain underlined in red and the
Proteus domain in green that it's highly
conserved so how do we go from this FD s
h4 mutation generates mitochondrial
defects to reduce spacial temporal
averaging well one possibility is
increased reactive oxygen species
mitochondrial defects often include it
caused the accumulation of reactive
oxygen species particularly super ox
hydrogen peroxide so lean on stain
looking for reactive oxygen species and
she found greatly increased super ah
sorry hydrogen peroxide accumulation you
can see it's very darkly stained
compared to wild-type and she also saw
superoxide accumulation
so here's wild-type that's got a little
bit and here's the mutant to see it it's
gotten very early and very much
increased in fairly variable superoxide
some sepals are very darkly stained
while others are not so if it's the
reactive oxygen species in the mutant
causing the phenotype then we should be
able to reproduce the phenotype by
treating plants with hydrogen peroxide
and that's in fact exactly what happened
when Leland dips wild-type plant in
hydrogen peroxide she can get out
variable sepal size particularly these
smaller sepals just like the mutant now
conversely if it's really the reactive
oxygen species we should be able to
remove reactive oxygen species from the
mutants and rescue it and that's what
happens so if she over expresses
catalase which degrades hydrogen
peroxide she can rescue normal see full
development and I'll just give you a
hint these sepals look even larger than
wild-type so how is Ross doing this
Ross affects a whole lot of signal
transduction mechanisms so it's probably
doing a bunch of different things but
one thing that it could be doing is
causing cross-linking of the cell wall
and so we looked at stiffness of the
cell wall and we find that in fact the
mutant cell walls are in general stiffer
so here's a
heatmap again where we've got stiff and
red and soft and blue you can see that
the mutant is overall stiffer than
wild-type so this makes us ask do
reactive oxygen species actually
regulate wild-type CL development and
when I looked at this I was really
excited because I saw that reactive
oxygen species were accumulating in the
wild-type
in a tip to base gradient as the seafoam
matures and that reminded me of the
growth pattern so in young sepals
they're growing rapidly throughout and
then they start to slow from the tip if
this blue slow growth and it descends
toward the base very much reminiscent of
this pattern so we can ask is Ross a
mechanism of maturation and to ask this
what we should see in the mutant is that
the mutant matures prematurely and
that's exactly what we see so we've got
wild-type you can see that it's starting
to mature from the tip just starting to
whereas the mutant is blue pretty much
throughout the sepal at these later time
points so it's occurring early so if
Ross is really acting as the signal
terminating growth in wild-type it
should increase sepal size if we remove
the Ross in wild-type so we take our
wild type plants and overexpress either
ascorbate oxidase or catalase and we can
get larger sepals just by reducing the
reactive oxygen species in wild-type
whereas if we overexpress our Bo HD
which is NADPH oxidase produces too much
Ross then we get smaller sepals
so to conclude we found that variability
produces regularity which is really kind
of a remarkable thought so their
variability undergoing spatial temporal
averaging gives rise to organ regularity
reactive oxygen species inhibit spatial
temporal averaging and they seem to form
a major signal inducing the maturation
of the organ and termination of growth
so Leyland published this in a beautiful
paper and developmental cell and in the
future we want to know how does Ross
affect spatial temporal averaging at a
more mechanistic level following up on
the mechanics what mechanism produces
Ross and wild-type to terminate siebel
growth and what other genes contribute
to sequel sighs regularity so Leland's
pulled out additional mutants but
variable organ size mutants and is
following up on a bunch of them and I
particularly might want to mention the
variable organ size two mutant the
encode gene encodes a mid domain
transcription factor this is being
worked on by menu N and this one is
really interesting so here's wild-type
with its four equal size evils here's
the mutant you can see variable c full
size it's really interesting because it
is affecting the primordial formation so
it's got defects where the primordium
don't form normally the sequel
primordium so it's affecting the other
end of the scale we saw fgs h4 is
affecting termination and vastu is now
picking initiation so we're hoping we
can put this all together so just to
summarize everything we've got our
spatial temporal averaging of cellular
ability to produce organ regularity
we've found a new patterning mechanism
where fluctuations in 18 will once or
pass a threshold during g2 that triggers
end or duplication via Lego and that
leads to proper organ curvature
and reactive oxygen species inhibit
spatial-temporal averaging and induce a
maturation and termination of growth I
want to mention a few other
collaborations going on with tips and
future directions and so Dena is also
looking at the relationship between
ploidy polyploidy with whole genome
duplication and endo polyploidy and how
that relates to cell size and organ size
and that that's really an extension of
our work in a new direction and that's
in collaboration with Jeff Doyle and Jo
is a joint graduate student with Mike
Scanlon and he's looking at asymmetric
division in the Moss apical cell and
Leland's been working club meeting with
members of Jos roses lab looking at the
dynamics of cuticle Ridge formation on
the sepal and there's a paper in
revision for a molecular plant and
Leland's also worked with Thomas
Bjorkman looking at Ross in broccoli and
it looks very much like a rabbit ops
assist accumulating the same way in the
sepals so I'd really like to thank the
members of my lab in particular Leland
did the work on organ size and Heather
did the work on a team Owen fluctuations
Sheehan was my first graduate student
and did the work that I didn't have time
to talk about insect 24 and I've told
you what Ming Ewan and Dana and Joe and
Lila are doing this works been funded by
the NSF and the human frontiers we have
fantastic collaborators particularly
henrik Johnson and James lock in their
postdocs Josie and Pao and a [ __ ]
Olivier Richard and Jim view Lee and so
I want to say that this is really the
result of the hard work of my lab and
the inspiration of their lab and their
ideas all coming together
and so here's my lab over time so I
really want to thank my lab has been
great working with you guys and I look
forward to all the future results we're
gonna have what you're gonna be
spectacular and I also want to thank our
collaborators these collaborations are
really intense we meet every two to
three weeks on skype we email all the
time these guys feel like lab members
and we're always talking to each other
we even meet in person this this one's
in Singapore and so it's been really
great collaborations and it's allowed us
to do things that we couldn't do just as
a lab by ourselves because we've got
these different disciplinary
perspectives coming together I'd like to
just finish by thanking plant biology in
the wild Institute for being my home for
the last five years and hopefully the
future
thank you and I'd be happy to take any
questions
this is you must be so we we have taken
a small look at this and what we looked
at is a 20 second 24 promoter we looked
at that because we have it available
former secretary for work and it ain't
no one definitely has more differences
because it results in 24 now that's
exactly what your viewers are not the
student assistant look at different
transcription factors and Heather it is
currently growing but I think either way
it comes out it's still interesting and
maybe we found a little property
so it the pack yeah so there's obviously
a pattern in time of how many cells are
entering a very application and it is
changing in time it's particularly
complicated by the fact that at the end
we've got to model with all that
happening and those cells are not
inherited locating it also extract
undergo a second so this is actually a
key point is that Giants the vagina cell
forms a serrano cell cannot form because
it takes an assault out of the poverty
process
the rate does change in time we've got
some clarification of that yeah
does the periodicity of this I'll say
will change or giant cells versus
regular self
so we don't actually know the answer to
that question it's something I'd really
like to know because one of the
hypotheses is that under duplicating
cells make cycle faster the problem is
we need a good soft cycle marker that
still cycles in dendritic cells the same
as in the case of ourselves and we don't
you don't get have that but we might
have looking
so yeah okay so the first question will
do question first question is do other
mutants that have Ross accumulation also
lead to this variable phenotype and this
actually is a very interesting point fkc
explores particular variable because PRS
accumulation is also variable and that
leaves what we've seen is that that
means the variability that size in
particular but just Ross accumulation
leads to much more variability in shape
so in for example when we overexpress
the NADPH oxidase and priests
accumulation of Ross we tend to get
equally smaller sepals but they have
much more variability of shape and for
something that I didn't mention in the
model when we decrease spatial-temporal
averaging by decreasing variability we
get we get more variable shape of
particulars so it fits with this facial
typography they're having a key role in
shaping smaller on the one side so it is
slightly more complex yes so the
question is is it necessary to have the
downstream target also have a threshold
we propose a downstream target because
it's a transcription factor having
something
I don't know that it's necessary for the
target have a threshold but it really
does give us nice dynamics that look
very much like our data with the soft
threshold of a table one and that's
really something we're going to have to
test for the future particularly whether
it Lego has some kind of harder
threshold like this or not and the
question is really is like you're the
target or is that something else and are
there basically
we do know genetically like accessory
is it possible than the FT Sh for Ross
effect is actually regulating 1801 as
well
I noticed that a female one has this
start going
which usually binds cholesterol an
oxidation of cholesterol is well
characterized and I wonderful break leg
active on the transcription factor
so the question is as Ross regulating it
tomorrow on very interesting hypothesis
so far we don't see any obvious defects
in giant cells and fth or beautiful
parts of Hurricane Ike Roscoe we don't
we don't see a connection of the
patterning there the start domain is
fascinating because yet as you say in
animals the optimal blind cholesterol
and we don't know what it's actually
doing in plants except that it's
important have been a lot of people
trying to figure it out and I'm hoping
that's another interesting question is
Ross an intracellular signal or not
what's thought is that how your
approximately superoxide can also
produce it's very interesting ideas we
have not yet tested that you also see
people in her
and one of you says we're going to do
the flat reveal but I do think there is
something interesting going on there how
much are each of these different species
moving in those that contributed to
things
okay well thank you very much this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu